What Happens to Sherlock Holmes' Mail
When Sir Arthur Conan Doyle first began writing
Sherlock Holmes stories back in the late 19th
century, 221B Baker Street didn’t exist.
While Baker Street itself existed, and still
exists today, the numbers on the street back
when Doyle wrote the Sherlock Holmes novels
and when Holmes was supposed to reside there
(1881 to 1904 according to Doyle’s original
stories) only went into the hundreds.
It would seem that Doyle intentionally picked
an address that didn’t exist.
This all changed in the 1930s when the street
numbers in London were rejigged and reallocated
to make things a little more streamlined.
During the reallocation, a recently constructed
building for the Abbey Road Building Society
(aka Santander), known as “Abbey House”
was awarded all of the odd numbers between
219 and 229.
Because the address 221 Baker Street now existed,
all of the mail that fans across the world
had inexplicably sent to Holmes not knowing
that he didn’t exist, now had a place to
be delivered.
It’s noted that as soon as the bank began
trading from the building on March 18, 1932,
they were inundated with dozens of letters
addressed to Holmes.
While most of the letters were basically just
fan mail or nice messages wishing the detective
well, the bank were surprised to find a decent
number of people who’d written to ask for
Holmes’ help.
Now you’re probably thinking that a large,
faceless corporation like a bank would have
dismissed these letters as an annoyance and
have them shredded or something, but that
didn’t happen.
Instead, the bank went out and hired someone
to serve as “Sherlock Holmes’ personal
secretary” and charged them with reading
and responding to the mail.
Rather than sending a stock reply on bank
stationary explaining that Sherlock Holmes
wasn’t real, this secretary would write
back explaining that Holmes had retired to
go live in the country and raise bees on a
farm in South Downs in Sussex.
Fans of Sherlock Holmes may recognise this
as being where Arthur Conan Doyle himself
claims the detective went in his twilight
years in the short stories, The Lion’s Mane,
The Blanched Soldiers and His Last Bow.
Needless to say, Abbey National did their
homework when it came to staying consistent
with Holmes’ back story.
According to Nikki Capar, who worked as Holmes’
secretary in the 1980s, she’d also sometimes
write back to fans as Sherlock Holmes using
quotes from the aforementioned stories, often
telling fans that she (Holmes) had “given
myself up entirely to that soothing life of
Nature for which I had so often yearned during
the long years spent amid the gloom of London.”
As it turned out, the bank quite enjoyed the
attention of sharing their address with one
of London’s most famous fictional residents,
so much so that they had a small plaque commissioned
to sit outside the building and on their 150th
anniversary even paid for the creation of
a bronze statue that currently sits outside
the Baker Street entrance to the tube.
Sherlock-holmes-museumIn 1990, though, things
turned a little sour when the Sherlock Holmes
museum opened nearby and suddenly decided
that they should be the only ones who were
allowed to open Sherlock Holmes’ fan mail.
Although the museum was located between 237
and 241 Baker Street, they argued that as
an authority on Sherlock Holmes, there were
better equipped to deal with his correspondence
than a billion dollar company with virtually
unlimited resources that had been doing an
admirable job at exactly that for about five
decades straight.
The museum even put a plaque outside their
building declaring that the museum was the
real home of Sherlock Holmes.
The courts didn’t agree and they ruled in
favour of the bank, since, well, they did
technically own 221 Baker Street and it wasn’t
their fault that people kept sending letters
there to a guy who didn’t exist.
The museum fought this decision for over a
decade until 2002, when the bank, which was
then known as Abbey National, moved its headquarters
to nearby Triton Square.
By this point, Westminster council had grown
pretty sick of dealing with the issue and
when the bank moved, they granted the museum
exclusive rights to use the address 221B Baker
Street, even though the museum itself still
resided between 237 and 241 Baker Street.